[Music]
hello to all my name is ja reign at
rock I am the founding ceo of account
but tri and I came today
with nicolas brunel who is the
scientific director of accounts masters then
against mettrie we have existed since  2011 we
have more than 120 employees and we have
a consulting firm our job is
to support our customers and this is a
particular point because among the
winners of confidence pointui and I
thank bertrand brunch vague julien
carraud ni and all  the counters
join me in thanking you for
its winners
our vocation is to help
customers be better at
artificial intelligence and to be better at
artificial intelligence confidence
versus mastery is also special
because we have a
research laboratory that we  let's call the accountant,
which is headed by nicolas brunel
and whose vocation is
to create partnerships with other
research laboratories for  r
work on a certain number of
subjects we publish scientific articles
we take part in international conferences
and we release
intellectual properties which are
published in open source in particular
we have worked for three years
on the subject of the measurement
of uncertainty c  is a software
called mappy and we are very
proud to participate in this work which
is constitutive of a
trustworthy artificial intelligence to be
trustworthy an
artificial intelligence must be able to say
when it is not
secrets was saying all I know
is that I know nothing what is
true in philosophy also applies
in technologies and
in artificial intelligence so we are going
to help our customers who are
French players but before
global scale d  to be able to realize
this trusted artificial intelligence
to produce technologies
that are capable of  tell its
users
when it does not know
the technology is extremely
important but what is even more
important than the technology is
the human and we believe that the human
must be part of the heart of the device
if the users  do
not understand artificial intelligence this
artificial intelligence will never be
a trustworthy artificial intelligence
that is why we believe
that training
continuous training initial training acculturation of
all bodies of society
will make it possible to ensure  that it
to ai be accepted use and be a
real artificial intelligence
trust to be trustworthy
linked to must be unia able to
explain itself and humans must be
able to understand artificial intelligence
thank you
thank you  I dreamed
[Music]